we just showed you the first 20 minutes
of our interview a few hours ago with
tony babalinsky
well-known international businessman who
was asked by the biden family to do
business with them
in china he met with the former vice
president joe biden
two separate times and they talked about
the china business deal
now this information has been out for
several weeks it's been the hands of a
number of different news organizations
the reason you're hearing a lot of this
for the first time tonight on this show
is because they have resolutely ignored
it and tried to suppress
the story joe biden has rarely been
asked about it though there is an
enormous amount of detail and
documentation
that no one has refuted because it's
real
this topic did come up because the
president pushed it at last week's
presidential debate
and what was notable was that joe biden
didn't deny
any specifics about his connections the
chinese communist party his family doing
business there
he himself participating in that
business
instead biden dismissed the entire story
out of hand and suggested that tony
babilinski
who was a veteran a former naval officer
was part of a russian disinformation
campaign
aimed at this country his evidence for
that well there wasn't any
instead he cited a letter from quote 50
foreign national
former national intelligence folks
almost all of them partisans
every one of them a liar none of them
had directly assessed the information
not one of them called tony babilinski
they knew nothing joe biden said that on
stage
and so when we spoke to tony boblins we
asked him his reaction to that and
here's what he said
tell me about the conversation that you
had with joe biden what did he say to
you uh you mean the morning after he
spoke that's right um it just
it was uh there was a 10 people running
around
getting him something to drink and we
were backstage in a cramped space
and he asked me to walk with him out to
the car and he just asked you know how i
did
and what i thought of his speech and i
thought he did a great job in the speech
and
obviously cancer is a very serious thing
that we should all be working together
to solve i just
lost a sister-in-law within the last two
weeks sadly to cancer
and um and then he just sort of asked me
to keep an eye on his son and his
brother
yeah well what do you think he meant by
that
um i think he was conscious of things
and you know
i can't speak for him maybe i would love
for him to go on record
um you know as i referenced earlier i'm
only sitting here because they have not
not only have they not gone on record
they've denied it
and they've tarred my family name and a
long history of serving this country
and have other congressmen now talking
about russian disinformation
this whole smear on joe biden comes from
the kremlin
i held a top-secret clearance from the
nsa and the doe
i served this country for four years in
one of the most elite
environments in the world naval nuclear
power training command
and to have a congressman out there
speaking about russian disinformation
or joe biden at a at a public debate
referencing russian disinformation when
he knows he sat
face to face with me that i was traveled
around the world with his son and his
brother
to say that and associate that with my
name is absolutely disgusting to me
have you did you complain about that i
mean to suggest that you were committing
treason
or a part of a foreign attack on our
democracy which is how they
characterized it i mean that's such a a
serious
and i think unfair charge did you bring
this up with them
well in basic form you're exactly right
they are publicly accusing me
of treason right now um treating me like
i'm insignificant
or the uh 50 years of history that my
family serve this country is
insignificant
and that's why i'm sitting here having
this i assure you this is the absolute
last place i want to be right now and
the last thing i want to be doing right
now
but i feel like i have a patriotic duty
to this country and every american
citizen
to go on record and to find the facts
for them and let them do their own work
let them decide how they view those
facts or not
but for the biden family to deny these
facts and then not only deny
them they could have just said no
comment but they didn't say no comment
they then brought in russian
disinformation and basically associated
my name with that
which is absolutely disgusting to me and
i
had to go on the record last weekend i
was in virginia
sadly my sister-in-law passed away at
around i think 6 38
saturday morning that's the wife of my
brother who spent 28 years serving this
country
as a naval flight officer and just
retired so you can imagine me dealing
with that and the tragedy of that
when i saw adam schiff go on record
talking about russian disinformation
after this email had been posted online
by the new york post and remember that
email was
to me from james gillier right it wasn't
you know i wasn't blind carbon or
cc'd on that it was to me stating that i
was going to be the ceo of this
enterprise
i had i was at the end of my rope and so
i crawled rob walker
and i told him that if that statement
isn't retracted
by an or uh congressman schiff by
midnight on sunday that i was going on
record and i was disclosing all the
facts
to the american government to the
american citizen and the world
i was hoping the bidens would do the
right thing or schiff would retract his
statement
but i could not allow another minute
another hour or a day
for my family's name to be associated or
muddied up around russian disinformation
so even as i sit here today i would ask
the biden family
to come on record and stop using my name
or associating it with russian
disinformation it's absolutely
disgusting
so this is rob walker the representative
of the biden family i believe his wife
worked for the biden family
um apparently so you said this to him
i won't go public i just want them to
retract
the accusation that i'm an instrument of
russian disinformation what did he say
that's correct um rob
is under a tremendous amount of stress
right uh obviously he's a wife and a
and a child and he uh
listen let me make some calls let me
call george who's hunter biden's
lawyer and and see what i can do but he
sort of presented it as if
that's going to be impossible for me to
get done and
you know i'm not naive i know that's not
impossible that's a single phone call
from joe biden to adam schiff saying
basically go on record and retract your
statement you got over your skis
and uh when i you know i was up late
that night and when the statement wasn't
retracted come monday morning
i was ready to go on record and what how
that record was
i was willing to go in front of any
senator any congressman
the department of justice the fbi or sit
here with you tucker
and basically provide the facts to the
american people and let them make their
decision
this isn't a political focus of mine
people were accusing my family of
treason
after i served this country and defended
this country
so the reason you wound up here in this
interview and and i just want to affirm
for our audience i don't think you had
any desire to do this interview
absolutely no desire is because nobody
else told your story
so were you surprised given the
the trove of documents you have given
the credibility
that i i think is apparent that you have
that
no other news organization took the time
to unpack
this story um surprise is probably uh
an understatement of the year shocked
because
um it would be different if this was my
word
against jim biden hunter biden and joe
biden
right that would be a very slippery
slope not something i would
take the personal and family risk on it
but i've provided more documents and
facts that validate times meetings
who participated that emailed to me on
may 13th was generated by somebody else
sent to me it wasn't me generating these
text messages
that i've provided are hunter biden in
the first person
jim biden in the first person james
gillier in the first person
rob walker in the first person it's not
me generating the text messages
it's them speaking so you can interview
them
the fbi can interview them our
government can interview them
but i was shocked that not only the
media is not only discussing this
they're going to the other extreme
they're dismissing it as russian
disinformation
this country has heard enough about
russia we went through three years of
every day
russia russia russia it's just absurd
the cold war is over and they're saying
it about your family
yes the biden family
knew that you're going public with this
and you spoke to rob walker about it
again
the self-described biden family
representative and biden family meaning
joe biden as well
what was his response when you let him
know that you were going public with
this
uh trying to coach me
trying to sort of say hey we don't want
to do that we don't want you know press
trucks out in front of our house
i'm going to have to move i could lose
my job
and all that um you know i'm not trying
to cause any harm to anyone in this
situation right let alone rob walker and
his family
james gillier and and his family um but
basically rob's position
was if you go on record with all these
facts you'll bury all of us
if he doesn't come out on record
i am uh providing the fact that you're
just gonna tell me just bury all of this
man
what was your response to that um
[Music]
i was focused on pushing these guys to
do the right thing
to demonstrate an ounce of integrity in
front of the american people
they all know the facts i live the facts
and luckily for the american people
all the facts are extremely well
documented
i'm irrelevant in this discussion so i
can write off but the american people
can read these texts listen to the
recording that you just played
read the legal documents that were
executed in delaware and they can form
their own conclusion they don't need me
to form the conclusion for them
give us a sense of your contacts with
hunter biden i just
a lot of this is complex there's a lot
that we're not and this is television so
we're not putting
you know everything that we have on this
right because we can't
but for those who might suspect that you
don't
didn't really have a lot of contact with
hunter biden
give us a sense of some of the places
where you had conversations with him
yeah and over what time frame so
obviously as we already discussed
throughout 2015
and 2016 while joe was still the sitting
vice president of the united states
these guys had been doing extensive work
around the world
in places like oman luxembourg romania
that i was being made aware of but i
obviously hadn't come off the bench
and agreed to be part of this i'm sorry
i've got to interrupt you there
oman luxembourg romania correct so they
don't speak any of these languages
neither one of these guys has any record
of success in
business neither one has a background in
international business why would they be
doing business in oman
luxembourg and romania because because
they have relationships and they have
the biden name that they're able to
set up meetings and get people to jump
through hoops
uh in an interest to garner favor with
the sitting vice president joe biden
so that so it sounds like gillier is a
legitimate
business guy a you know someone who's
who's fluent in the language
james gillier you know served his
country he's british yes
he's traveled around the world for
decades he's a very low profile
right individual but he is uh he's sharp
and he's as legitimate as they come it
sounds it
but hunter biden and jim biden have a
well-documented decades-long
record of business disasters did you get
any sense that either one of these guys
was qualified to be conducting this kind
of business the only qualification they
had was their biden name
but they seemed to have parlayed that
into quite a few deals in quite a few
countries and i interrupted you so so
give me
continue with where they were doing
these deals yeah so you had asked you
know
uh the extent of my communication with
hunter biden so when i
uh decided to come off the bench and and
uh entertain me in the ceo of signal
hawk holdings
um obviously i was brought up to speed
on the work that they had been doing in
oman
luxembourg france romania
kazakhstan and stuff like that because
that was all going to be
integrated into seine hawk holdings um
and so you asked to the extent that i
spent time with hunter biden
i personally was in bucharest romania
with hunter biden
jim biden james gillier rob walker
i was in monaco for the you know annual
grand prix there
i was supposed to sit with hunter biden
i met him
i met on the patio of his hotel and i
sat there and waited for two hours
and you can imagine how angry and i was
frustrated
after sitting there for two hours
waiting for him without a text a phone
call to let me know
i can't make it or i'm tied up and uh in
a text that i think you guys are aware
of and saw
the next day he aggressively comes back
at me
that uh he couldn't attend the meeting
that he himself
set up i stepped away from family and
friends on
on the yacht that i was on with my
friends to go sit with him
uh for a couple hours and uh he's
effectively screaming into the phone
that he could not
pick up the uh phone and text me because
he was with the ukrainians
and mikkola the founder of barisma
and that he was fighting for the only
income he has on the kazakhstan deal
that apparently he negotiated now i had
no exposure
to kazakhstan deal i'm not aware of any
of the particulars of the kazakhstan
deal
i just know for a fact there is a
kazakhstan deal
because hunter biden in first person
told me there was
in the text that i think you guys have
and you will show to the american people
it's not my job to determine what that
deal is i'll leave that up to the
fbi or the senate and the congress to
figure that out
i just want to restate this you are not
a grifter
you're not someone who's selling access
you're a legitimate businessman who's
done
deals in a lot of different countries so
i just want you to assess once more
is there anything about hunter biden's
personal experience personal
qualifications
that would justify him doing a deal in
kazakhstan
uh absolutely nothing the only thing
that he had was the biden family name
and the fact that his father at one
point obviously was a sitting vice
president
and potentially would run as a future
president it sounds like
a remarkably ambitious international
business program they had running
extensive uncle extensive
um this is a small point but i i i can't
get over it
so you saw a number of reporters say
again in an effort to bat away your
story your testimony on this that
the chairman referred to in a bunch of
these emails
was not joe biden it was in fact the
government of china when you see people
refer to the chairman thinks this the
chairman thinks that
they're talking about china and not joe
biden so i want to put up on the screen
here is a text message you received from
honor biden to you
hey tony i have an idea in light of the
fact that we are an impasse of sorts and
both james's lawyers and my
chairman gave an emphatic no i think we
should all meet in romania on tuesday
next week
so you're hearing reporters say that
chairman was in fact
the chinese government here you have rob
walker
responding to you clearly there's some
confusion over this and he's saying i'll
put this on the screen now
when he said when hunter biden said his
chairman
he was talking about his dad correct
there's two chairmen in the story
there's chairman yee who's the chairman
of cfc
yeah and that text from hunter biden he
was not talking about the chairman of
cfc
and what hunter is referencing there is
he spoke with his father
and his father is giving an emphatic no
to the ass that i had which was
putting proper governance in place
around oneida holdings
so joe biden is
vetoing your plan for putting
stricter governance in the company i
mean and it's
it's right here in the emails yeah
tucker i want to be very careful
in front of the american people that is
not me writing that
that is not me claiming that that is
hunter biden
writing on his own phone typing in that
i spoke with
my chairman referencing his father if
the world thinks that that my chairman
is not his father
then hunter biden would come forward and
go on record and state to the world but
you have
the biden family representatives rob
walker saying right here may 19th
no when he said his chairman he was
talking about his dad
exactly